Bevor wir mit diesem Video beginnen,
muss ich eine Warnung aussprechen:
die kommenden Minuten werden das Narrativ und das
Bild, welches die meisten von Euch über China,
die Welt und die Weltordnung dieses Jahrhunderts
in den Köpfen tragen, zum Einsturz bringen.
Am Anfang wird Euch alles noch sehr
vertraut vorkommen, doch wir werden ein
Vorurteil nach dem anderen zertrümmern
und zwar nicht mit Hilfe von Gerüchten,
sensationsgeilen Spekulationen
oder Verschwörungstheorien,
wie so viele andere YouTube-“Analysten“,
sondern mit harten Zahlen und klaren Fakten.
Und wenn ich jetzt so’ Typ wäre, der sich gern
die Haare färbt hätte und noch mehr mit den
Händen herumfuchtelt, würde ich dieses Video
wohl: „Die Zerstörung der KPC!“ nennen. Denn
wir werden Euch beweisen, dass ein Großteil der
nationalistischen Prahlerei und ideologischen
Propaganda der Kommunistischen Partei Chinas,
mit welcher sie unermüdlich das weltweite
Publikum zu beeinflussen versucht,
auf verdammt tönernen Füßen steht.
Seid Ihr dazu bereit? Gut, dann schnallt Euch an,
denn was jetzt kommt ist schon ziemlich
harter Tobak und am Ende dieser steilen
Fahrt werdet ihr perfekt verstehen, warum
der Titel dieses Videos absolut Sinn ergibt.
Also… los geht’s!
Eines ist uns allen klar: Nach seinem
jahrhundertelangem Dornröschenschlaf ist der
chinesische Riese endlich erwacht.
Während der letzten vier Jahrzehnte lag das
Wirtschaftswachstum im Reich der Mitte im Schnitt
bei etwa 10 % pro Jahr. In dieser Zeit hat sich
China von einer ländlich dominierten Gesellschaft
aus armen Bauern zu einem modernen Industrieland
mit gigantischen Metropolen entwickelt.
Nach Angaben der Weltbank
stieg das inflationsbereinigte Pro-Kopf-BIP um
mehr als das 24-fache, die durchschnittliche
Lebenserwartung stieg um mehr als 10 Jahre und
mehr als 700 Millionen Chinesen ließen die Armut
hinter sich.
Tatsächlich hat die Weltbank neue Schätzungen
veröffentlicht, nach denen die chinesische
Wirtschaft im Jahr 2020 bereits vor der
US-amerikanischen lag, wenn das BIP um die
Unterschiede bei den Lebenshaltungskosten
bereinigt wird. Und das sagt nicht nur die
Weltbank, welche ja erst kürzlich durch einen
Datenmanipulationsskandal auf Betreiben Chinas
aufgefallen ist. Auch die Schätzungen des
IWF weisen in genau die gleiche Richtung.
Selbst das Coronavirus schien irgendwie geradezu
dafür geschaffen zu sein, die Überlegenheit des
chinesischen Modells zu demonstrieren. Peking
schaffte es, selbst das Krisenjahr 2020 mit guten
Wirtschaftsdaten abzuschließen, während sich der
Rest der entwickelten Welt durch sein katastrophal
missratenes Pandemie-Manamegent bildlich
gesprochen nicht nur in einen Fuß schoss, sondern
gleich in beide und dazu noch in eine Hand.
Umfragen zufolge haben all diese Veränderungen
dazu geführt, dass eine große Mehrheit der
Menschen glaubt, dass China die Vereinigten
Staaten bald als Supermacht Nummer eins ablösen
wird. Gehörst auch Du dazu?
Nun, das ist nicht besonders überraschend.
Denk mal einen Moment darüber nach:
In der kollektiven Vorstellung produzieren
die Chinesen alles, was die Welt braucht.
Alle sind von ihnen abhängig geworden. Sie
sind nun praktisch die Herren der halben Welt.
Und was willst
du von mir hören? Die Daten scheinen eindeutig
zu sein: China hat ein höheres bereinigtes BIP,
höhere Investitionen, höhere Handelsströme
und ein höheres Wirtschaftswachstum.
Die Chinesen
außerdem auch die zweitgrößten Gläubiger der
USA. Nur Japan hält noch mehr US-Staatsanleihen.
Du siehst also: die Amis dürften
sich auf etwas gefasst machen,
denn sie werden gerade jetzt in diesem
Moment von der chinesischen Walze überrollt!
Der Tipp an alle Opportunisten scheint also
zu lauten: Jetzt ist die letzte Gelegenheit,
noch umzusatteln und auf die Seite des Gewinners
zu wechseln! Oder: eben noch tiefer in Xi Jinpings
Allerwertesten zu kriechen.
Aber Moment mal! Lasst uns mal kurz innehalten,
damit ob der ganzen China-Panik bei den einen
und China-Euphorie bei den anderen
nicht die Pferde mit uns durchgehen.
Bedeutet all das
denn wirklich, dass wir alle dazu verdammt sind,
unter chinesischer Vorherrschaft zu leben? Dass
das einstige Land der Drei Reiche mit Sicherheit
die nächste große Supermacht der Welt werden wird
und damit die Zeit der USA als wirtschaftliche
und militärische Hegenomialmacht vorbei ist?
Nun, passt jetzt lieber
mal gut auf, denn in China sind die Dinge nicht
immer so, wie sie auf den ersten Blick scheinen.
Lasst uns doch mal die besagen Daten
etwas genauer unter die Lupe nehmen! Denn in ihnen
können wir extrem interessante Dinge entdecken,
von denen in den sensationslüsternen
Medien nicht so oft die Rede ist.
Also: aufgepasst!
(DIE WIRTSCHAFT DES DRACHEN)
Vorweg müssen wir uns natürlich im Klaren
darüber sein, dass die chinesischen Daten
mit äußerster Vorsicht zu genießen sind.
Wir wissen aus der Vergangenheit,
dass diese… wie soll ich’s sagen... möglicherweise
nicht ganz zuverlässig sind. Aber darüber haben
wir bereits auf VisualPolitik in einem
anderen Video gesprochen. Ich werde es
für Dich in der Beschreibung und oben
rechts hinter dem i-Symbol verlinken.
Hast Du überhaupt schon unseren Kanal abonniert,
damit Du keines dieser informativen Videos mehr
verpasst? Falls nein, dann aber schnell
und auch das Glöckchen nicht vergessen!
So, können wir weitermachen...? Ich danke Dir!
Und jetzt zurück zu unseren China-Daten! Glaub
mir, ob die Daten nun mehr oder weniger der
Wahrheit entsprechen sind, ist das geringste
Problem bei der Einschätzung, ob China die USA
überholen wird oder nicht.
Schließlich ist es unbestreitbar, dass
das Land in den letzten 40 Jahren ein
enormes Wachstum und eine enorme Entwicklung
erlebt hat. Daran gibt es keinen Zweifel.
Sieh dir nur die riesigen
Wolkenkratzer, die moderne Infrastruktur, die
boomende Mittelschicht oder die neuen chinesischen
Unternehmen wie Alibaba oder Tencent an, die
ihre Tentakel in die ganze Welt ausstrecken.
Aber: das ist nur die halbe Wahrheit,
jene die Dir überall erzählt wird.
Auf der anderen Hälfte der Wahrheit – der
verborgenen – befindet sich eine ganz andere
Tatsache, die jedoch in diesem Fall maßgeblich
ist: Nämlich die Tatsache, dass die Vereinigten
Staaten noch immer viel, viel, viel reicher
sind als China. Und was noch wichtiger ist:
Die Kluft zwischen den beiden Wirtschaftsgiganten
wird nicht kleiner, sondern immer größer.
Ok, ok,
warte einen Moment! Mach’ ich jetzt Witze? Will
ich Dir hier entgegen dem, was Du den ganzen Tag
von überall hört, jetzt echt verklickern, dass
der Abstand zwischen den USA und China wächst?
Und dazu noch zu Ungunsten Chinas? Haben wir nicht
eben selbst gesagt, dass Chinas bereinigtes BIP
die USA bereits übertroffen hat?
Also… ich will Euch nicht auf Folter spannen.
Das Problem ist nämlich, dass das BIP ein
Bruttoindikator ist, mit dem man weder die Kosten
noch die Schöpfung von Wohlstand geeignet messen
kann und auch nicht die Marge, die ein Land
braucht, um sich als Supermacht abzusetzen.
Hier ein Beispiel zu veranschaulichung:
Seit dem Jahr 2000 ist der
Anteil der Millionäre an der Gesamtbevölkerung in
China nur um einen halben Prozentpunkt gestiegen,
während der Millionärsanteil der USA
zehnmal so schnell wuchs. Heute verfügen
fast 9 % der amerikanischen Erwachsenen über ein
Nettovermögen von mehr als einer Million Dollar.
Nach Angaben der
Credit Suisse hat sich die Vermögenskluft zwischen
Amerikanern und Chinesen seit 2011 um mehr als 12
Billionen Dollar vergrößert.
Aber wie ist das möglich? Ist China nicht
die Fabrik der Welt? Ja, das stimmt, aber das
Problem ist, dass es eine sehr ineffiziente
Fabrik ist. China produziert viel Zeugs,
das sein BIP in die Höhe treibt, aber um das
zu erreichen, muss es enorme Produktionskosten
aufbringen. Das heißt, die chinesische
Wirtschaft ist groß, aber furchtbar ineffizient.
Tja, da werden jetzt viele staunen, denn das
entspricht gar nicht dem Bild, welches uns
von den emsigen und bescheidenen
Chinesen immer gezeichnet wird.
Aber denke einen
Moment darüber nach! Eigentlich kennst Du diese
Information bereits. Sie wird Dir allerdings
immer in einem anderen Kontext präsentiert.
Z.B. wenn es um Umweltverschmutzung geht.
Denn wenn ich Ineffizient sage, ich beziehe mich
nicht auf die Höhe der Gehälter chinesischer
Arbeiter, sondern auf den Produktions-Input,
den gewaltigen Verbrauch von Energie, Wasser,
Rohstoffen und die Zahl der Arbeitskräfte,
die zur Erfüllung einer bestimmten Aufgabe
benötigt werden.
Außerdem wird ein großer Teil der
chinesischen Produktion für die Befriedigung
der Grundbedürfnisse der 1,4 Milliarden Einwohner
und der chinesischen Regierung selbst verbraucht.
Das Problem ist, dass das BIP
die jährliche Produktion, sagen wir mal brutto,
misst, aber weder die Kosten noch den Überschuss,
der schließlich zu Reichtum wird, berücksichtigt.
Tja, aus der Modellgläubigkeit und
weit verbreiteten Missinterpretation
von Indikatoren – auch durch Politik und Presse -
erwachsen eben die größten Irrtümer unserer Zeit.
Und sie sind, sobald sie sich in den Köpfen als
Narrativ festgesetzt haben, kaum noch auszurotten.
Dabei kann durch einfache Vergleiche und etwas
Nachdenken jeder selbst drauf kommen. Warum
zum Beispiel hat Indien das fünfthöchste BIP der
Welt und ist gleichzeitig ein so verarmtes Land,
dass es kaum über die Ressourcen verfügt,
um die große Mehrheit seiner Bevölkerung
aus der Armut zu befreien, geschweige
denn als Supermacht auftreten zu können?
Nun die Antwort lautet auch hier wieder:
das BIP ist der falsche Indikator, um das
Weltmachtpotential eines Landes zu messen, denn
es berücksichtigt wie gesagt nicht die Effizienz
seiner Wirtschaftsaktivitäten.
Fazit: Sei sehr vorsichtig mit den Daten
und Indikatoren, die du verwendest,
um Schlussfolgerungen zu ziehen.
Aber lassen wir uns nicht ablenken, denn ich
weiß, was du dich fragst: Wie ineffizient ist
die chinesische Wirtschaft denn nun eigentlich
und warum in aller Welt ist sie das überhaupt?
Nun... Chinas Wirtschaftswachstum lässt sich fast
ausschließlich durch das Wachstum
der produktiven Ressourcen erklären.
Keine Angst, ich werde Dir genau
erklären, was das bedeutet.
Also… 90 bis 97% des chinesischen
Wirtschaftswachstums war mit der
Eingliederung von mehr Arbeitskräften in die
Industrieproduktion und den Investitionen in
Sachkapital verbunden. Im Gegensatz dazu machte
die sogenannte "Totale Faktorproduktivität"
nur 3 bis 7 Prozent des chinesischen
Wirtschaftswachstums Wirtschaft aus.
Und jetzt denkst
Du vielleicht: Ok, Mark, warum schmeißt Du alter
Klugscheißer mir hier schon wieder irgendwelche
ökonomischen Fachbegriffe um die Ohren?
Gut, Du hast vollkommen Recht. Aber ich
bin ja auch kein Volkswirt und muss mir
das in einfaches Deutsch übersetzen.
Also, einfach ausgedrückt besagt die
„Totale Faktorproduktivität“ wie viel
Prozent des Wirtschaftswachstums
nicht auf den Einsatz von mehr
Produktionsfaktoren wie Arbeit
und Kapital zurückzuführen ist.
Noch einfacher gesagt: sie steht dafür, dass
mit „weniger mehr erreicht wurde“. Also mit
weniger Input wurde mehr Output erzielt.
Der Rest des Wirtschaftswachstums – also
das Gegenteil der totalen Faktorproduktivität
– ist das „mehr durch mehr“ – wenn also mehr
Outut einfach nur durch den Einsatz
von noch mehr Input erzeugt wird.
Lass uns das noch mit einem Beispiel
illustrieren. Stell dir vor, wir haben zwei
Fabriken, die es beide schaffen, die gleiche Menge
an Gütern pro Tag zu produzieren. Aber die erste
hat eine Maschine und einen Arbeiter, während die
zweite zwei Arbeiter und zwei Maschinen hat.
Offensichtlich ist die erste Fabrik viel
effizienter, produktiver, sie schafft es,
mit weniger mehr zu erreichen, so dass sie
einerseits weniger Kapital investieren und
damit weniger Schulden anhäufen muss und
andererseits Produktionsfaktoren - eine
Maschine und einen Arbeiter – frei
sind, um andere Unternehmen zu gründen.
Siehst du den Unterschied? Nun, genau
das passiert im Fall von China. Da die
Produktivität sehr niedrig ist, musste
die Regierung riesige Summen investieren,
um das Wirtschaftswachstum aufrechtzuerhalten.
Und das führte zu einer Explosion der Schulden.
Um dir eine Vorstellung davon zu geben: Zwischen
2007 und 2017 hat sich Chinas Verschuldung
außerhalb des Finanzsektors vervierfacht
und ist damit stärker gestiegen als in jedem
anderen Land. Sie hat sogar schon den Schnitt der
fortgeschrittenen Volkswirtschaften übertroffen.
Das ist ein Faktor, der
Schlagzeilen wie diese erklärt:
(Evergrande und
das Ende von Chinas "Bauen, bauen, bauen"-Modell.
Die spektakuläre Auflösung des Immobilienkonzerns,
der 2020 mit 41 Mrd. USD bewertet wurde, offenbart
tiefe Schwächen in Pekings Wachstumsstrategie. FT)
Und machen wir uns
nichts vor. Dieser Trend kann nicht dauerhaft
aufrechterhalten werden, obwohl dies in der
Vergangenheit auf Biegen und Brechen versucht
wurde. Das Ergebnis: Überinvestitionen haben
überall zu einer Menge Überproduktion geführt
haben, d.h. Fabriken, die nicht gebraucht werden,
Geisterstädte und steigende Kosten in der
gesamten Wirtschaft - man denke nur an die Zinsen,
die höheren Energiekosten und höhere Löhne, da
ja die unproduktiven Firmen den produktiven die
Arbeitskräfte weg nehmen und dadurch weniger
Arbeitskräfte auf dem Markt verfügbar sind.
So kam es, wie es kommen musste: das chinesische
Wachstum hat sich in den letzten Jahren stetig
verlangsamt.
Der springende Punkt ist nun, dass die Vereinigten
Staaten im Gegensatz zu China eine viel
effizientere Wirtschaft haben und ihre Unternehmen
zu den konkurrenzfähigsten der Welt gehören. Denn
ihre Produktivität pro Arbeitnehmer ist nicht
nur schon heute viel höher ist als in China,
sondern der Unterschied wird auch immer größer.
Außerdem liegen
die Kosten der USA für soziale Absicherung und
innere Sicherheit viel niedriger als in China,
da sie gegenüber dem asiatischen Riesen ja eine
viermal kleinere Bevölkerung versorgen müssen.
China ist ein Land, das trotz seiner geringeren
Produktion viel mehr Menschen ernähren, kleiden
und heizen muss, was bedeutet, dass die über diese
Grundversorgung hinausgehene Produktion, welche
also zur Anhäufung von Wohlstand genutzt werden
kann, viel geringer ausfällt.
Das Ergebnis: China wächst, aber die USA werden
reicher und reicher. Und je reicher du bist,
desto mehr Möglichkeiten hast du,
deinen Supermachtstatus zu erhalten.
Na, haben Euch diese Fakten jetzt überrascht?
Ich wette, dass die meisten von Euch die Welt
jetzt etwas anders sehen als noch vor 10 Minuten!
Aber wartet einen Moment, denn wir haben gerade
erst damit angefangen, Euer Weltbild zum Einsturz
bringen!
Nach Schätzungen von Weltbank und der Vereinten
Nationen macht das Humankapital - also Bildung,
Fähigkeiten und Erfahrung - mehr als die
Hälfte des Wohlstands der meisten Länder
und bis zu 80 % des Wohlstands der am
weitesten entwickelten Nationen aus.
Und dies stellt nur eine der
großen Stärken der US of A dar.
In China haben zum
Beispiel nur etwas mehr als 10 % der Arbeitskräfte
einen Hochschulabschluss, in den USA sind es 44 %.
Und ich weiß was Ihr einwenden
werdet: viele dieser Hochschulen
sind entweder miese Community-Colleges. nicht
vergleichbar mit z.B. europäischen Hochschulen,
oder sie sind schweineteuer. Darüber haben
wir ja vor kurzem ein eigenes Video gedreht.
Aber Ihr dürft die Qualität der amerikanischen
Hochschulen hier nicht mit Europa vergleichen,
sondern eben mit China. Ein valider Vergleich
muss zudem die schwachen Unis mit den schwachen
und die besten mit den besten vergleichen.
Nur so erhalten wir ein vollständiges Bild.
Und hier stehen die US-Unis weitaus besser
da, was verständlich ist, denn in China gibt
es nicht einmal freien Zugang zum Internet
oder zu wissenschaftlicher Forschung aus dem
Rest der Welt.
Das Ergebnis: Während die beste chinesische
Universität im "Center for World University
Rankings" auf Platz 58 erscheint, besetzen
die USA gleich 29 der 50 obersten Plätze im
Ranking der besten Universitäten der Welt.
Und nein, die anderen Rankings unterscheiden
sich nicht maßgeblich davon. Ihr
seht also: gerade an der Spitze,
wo es um die Ausbildung der Führungseliten der
Welt geht, besteht ein himmelweiter Unterschied.
Als Konsequenz gehen natürlich auch viele kluge
Köpfe aus China lieber in die USA zum studieren
als andersherum. Und viele von ihnen bleiben
dann dort – oder auch in Europa. Natürlich gilt
das auch für viele bereits in ihrer Heimat gut
ausgebildete Chinesen: in Übersee finden sie eben
bessere Arbeits- und Lebensbedingungen. Ein steter
Braindrain, dessen Ende nicht abzusehen ist.
Auf diese Weise kommt
also noch erschwerend hinzu, dass China jedes Jahr
Hunderttausende seiner besten Talente ans Ausland
verliert, darunter Zehntausende von Ingenieuren,
Wissenschaftlern, Erfindern und Unternehmern.
Kluge und selbständige Menschen fühlen
sich in einem totalitären Zensur-,
Überwachungs- und Bevormundungsstaat eben
nicht unbedingt super-wohl. Sie brauchen
zumindest eine halbwegs glaubwürdige Illusion der
Freiheit - wovon China Lichtjahre entfernt ist.
Die USA hingegen sind die
absoluten und auf unabsehbare Zeit unangefochtenen
Meister dieses Fachs. Und deswegen ströhmen jedes
Jahr eine Million qualifizierte ausländische
Arbeitskräfte ins Land der "begrenzten
Möglichkeiten". Darunter befinden sich Tausende
der höchstqualifizierten Wissenschaftler und
Ingenieure aus der ganzen Welt inklusive China.
Und diese migrantische Leistungselite kommt
nicht in die Staaten, um dort auf Staatskosten
Däumchen zu drehen und Drogen zu verticken. Nein,
sie kommen, um sich und ihre neue
Heimat so gut voranzubringen, wie es
nur geht. Und glaubt mir: die können das auch!
Die Zahlen sprechen hier nun mal ein glasklare
Sprache.
Wenn wir dies mit einer
Analogie aus dem Mannschaftsport
erklären wollten, müssten wir sagen:
Die USA haben einfach den bessten Kader,
das mit Abstand beste Trainingszentrum und
saugen außerdem jedes Jahr einfach die besten
Spieler vom Transfermarkt weg. Den anderen
Mannschaften bleibt dann nur noch die zweite
Wahl. Mit der lässt sich die Tabellenspitze
vielleicht ein-, zweimal mit viel Glück und
hohem Aufwand erklimmen. Aber auf Dauer kehrt
immer der Favorit an seinen Stammplatz zurück.
Die Amis haben durch die Konstellation all dieser
Faktoren quasi ein Abo auf den Meistertitel.
Apropos Abo: Du weißt schon!
Wenn Du VisualPolitik abonnierst,
machen wir auch Dich automatisch zum Meister der
Weltpolitik! Also: Du weißt, was Du zu tun hast!
Aber zurück zur
US-Mannschaft. Deren Torbilanz, also ich meine...
das höhere Produktivitätsniveau ist eben darauf
zurückzuführen, dass sich das Team USA weitgehend
auf hochwertige und technologisch am weitesten
fortgeschrittene Produkte spezialisiert, was
China zwar nachzuahmen versucht, aber eben nicht
in einem ausreichenden Verhältnis zu seiner
riesigen Bevölkerungszahl hinbekommen kann.
Tja, wer hätte gedacht, dass gerade dem
1,4-Millarden-Reich die Leute dafür fehlen
würden? Aber dazu später mehr!
Denn ein anderer sehr wichtiger Faktor, der dabei
oft überhaupt nicht berücksichtigt wird, ist die
Tatsache, dass von jedem Dollar chinesischer
Produktion, der in die USA exportiert wird,
55 Cent auf Komponenten und Dienstleistungen
entfallen, die in den USA selbst hergestellt
werden. Technologisch sind die Chinesen also
mehr von den USA abhängig als umgekehrt.
Außerdem wird Xi Jinpings
zunehmende Einmischung in private Unternehmen -
wie zum Beispiel sein Feldzug gegen die großen
privaten Technologieunternehmen des Landes - wohl
auch in Zukunft nicht gerade zu einer Steigerung
der Produktivität beitragen.
Das Gleiche gilt für die Korruption oder die
Hindernisse, welche die Kommunistische Partei
all jenen Unternehmern auferlegt,
die nicht ihrer Partei angehören.
Wir haben darüber bereits in einem Video
über Alibaba berichtet: interne Graben- und
Verteilungskämpfe zwischen verschiedenen
Fraktionen der KPC werden direkt auf dem
Rücken der stark wachsenden Unternehmen und ihren
Gründern ausgetragen. Schließlich will keiner die
üppigen Profite und die Macht dieser Firmen den
Parteigenossen vom anderen Flügel überlassen.
Und
wir haben noch ein letztes, nicht gerade
geringfügiges Problem: die Demografie.
China altert viel schneller als die Vereinigten
Staaten und seine Bevölkerung über 65 wird sich
bis Mitte des Jahrhunderts mehr als verdreifachen.
Wie du in dieser Grafik also sehen kannst,
ist die Entwicklung der beiden Länder sehr,
sehr unterschiedlich:
Dem asiatische
Riesen steht einen gewaltiges Rentenproblem ins
Haus und die Uhr für diese soziale Katastrophe
tickt unerbittlich. Chinas Bevölkerung
wird in den nächsten Jahrzehnten stark
schrumpfen und der höhere Anteil
der über 65-Jährigen bedeutet,
dass das Land Ressourcen aus der Produktion
abzweigen muss, um sie zu versorgen.
Ja, und ich weiß, dass einige von Euch jetzt
einwenden werden, dass Peking doch nun die
3-Kind-Politik eingeführt hat und damit doch
noch die Kurve kriegen kann. Aber Pustekuchen:
erstens kann sie sich ja wirtschaftlich
erst frühestens in 30 Jahren auswirken,
wenn die Kinder geboren, aufgezogen,
auf Weltniveau ausgebildet und im
produktiven Leben angekommen sind.
Und dann ist es nun mal zu spät,
denn der Renter-Tsunami wird schon viele
Jahre früher über das Land hinwegfegen.
Zweitens ist eine politische Vorgabe die
eine Sache und ihre Umsetzung „im Ehebett“
eine ganz andere. Und derzeit sieht es
gar nicht danach aus, dass die Chinesen
mehr Kinder bekommen wollen. Viele können
sie sich finanziell einfach nicht leisten
oder haben einfach keine Lust. Nach jüngsten
Umfragen befindet sich die Paarungsbereitschaft
bei der überwältigende Mehrheit der jungen
Bevölkerung auf einem absoluten Tiefpunkt.
Was China bräuchte, um die demographische
Katastrophe abzuwenden, wäre ein absolutes
Wunder – aber schon von 10 Jahren. Von
diesem Wunder ist jedoch auch auf lange
Sicht nichts zu sehen – im Gegenteil: es
gibt nur eine Richtung: weiter bergab.
Wenn wir hingegen über den Pazifik in die USA
schauen, sehen wir dort ganz klar über eine
wesentlich gesündere Demografie und damit
eine langfristig bessere Zukunftsperspektive.
Und so sehr diese Tatsache auf Xi Jinpings
Missfallen stoßen mag: es sieht nicht danach
aus, dass Chinas Wirtschaftskraft die der USA
in den kommenden Jahrzehnten übertreffen wird und
dass das asiatische Land über genügend Ressourcen
verfügt, um wirklich in jenen Kampf um den ersten
Platz als führende Supermacht der Welt antreten
zu können.
Wie bereits gesagt: Die Daten sprechen
hier nun mal ein glasklare Sprache.
Aber Achtung! Denn beim
Wettrennen um die Weltherrschaft, geht es nicht
nur um die Wirtschaft. Wer die Welt dominieren
will braucht nicht irgendeine Armee, sondern
langfristig die mit Abstand beste der Welt.
Und wie sieht es damit in China aus? Lasst und
das auch noch schnell unter die Lupe nehmen!
(DAS SCHWERT DES DRACHENS)
In einem zukünftigen Video werden wir Euch
Chinas Militärstrategie genauer erklären. An
dieser Stelle reicht es zu wissen, dass Peking
im Wesentlichen darauf abzielt, eine regionale
Großmacht zu werden.
Denn die Wahrheit ist einfach, dass die
Unterschiede auf globaler Ebene im Moment
enorm sind.
Zum Beispiel sind die Militärausgaben der USA
etwa dreimal so hoch wie die Chinas. Und ja,
es stimmt, dass chinesische Soldaten viel
schlechter bezahlt werden, aber es stimmt auch,
dass die chinesische Armee 1,2 Millionen mehr
Soldaten hat als die der Vereinigten Staaten.
Das Ergebnis ist, dass die chinesischen
Streitkräfte eine Menge Sold, eine Menge
Unterhaltskosten und vor allem auch eine Menge
Soldatenpensionen am Hals haben. Und das stellt
eine gigantische Belastung dar.
So wird beispielsweise geschätzt,
dass die steigenden Personalkosten
seit 2008 mehr als die Hälfte der Erhöhungen im
chinesischen Militärhaushalt aufgefressen haben.
Und natürlich ist die reine Anzahl an
Soldaten heutzutage alles andere als ein Synonym
für militärische Schlagkraft. Ganz im Gegenteil.
Was zählt, ist eine gut ausgerüstete,
gut ausgebildete und logistisch perfekt
aufgestellte Armee. Und weißt du was? Die USA sind
in diesem Vergleich nun mal der klare Gewinner.
Die Zahlen sind so überwältigend, dass es sich
nicht lohnt, mit ihnen dieses Video unnötig in
die Länge zu ziehen. Aber nicht traurig sein:
Wie gesagt machen wir dazu ein separates.
Außerdem hat die chinesische Armee keine
echte Kampferfahrung und ihre Ausbildung ist
viel schlechter. Das liegt unter anderem daran,
dass die chinesischen Truppen geschlagene 20 %
ihrer Zeit damit verbringen, die kommunistische
Ideologie der chinesischen Regierung zu pauken
und an politischen Versammlungen teilzunehmen.
Anders lässt sich ihre Loyalität wohl nicht
sicherstellen, was auch schon wieder
viel über deren Kampfmoral aussagt.
Und obwohl es stimmt, dass
China große Fortschritte in der Militärtechnologie
macht - wir werden hier auf VisualPolitik bald
darüber sprechen, also vergiss nicht das Abo -,
ist der Abstand zu den Vereinigten Staaten immer
noch galaktisch.
Erschwerend kommt hinzu, dass Chinas Grenzen
eine große Belastung für seine Streitkräfte
darstellen. Warum? Nun, weil China mit den meisten
seiner Nachbarn nicht besonders gut auskommt
und deshalb gezwungen ist, einen großen Teil
seiner Armee über das ganze Land zu verteilen.
Zu groß wäre das Risiko, dass eines der
Nachbarländer oder eine unterdrückte Minderheit
während einer eventuellen Schwächephase
des roten Riesen in Versuchung kommt,
mal schnell Tatsachen in einer die vielen
umstrittenen Grenzregionen zu schaffen.
Die chinesische Armee widmet daher fast die Hälfte
ihrer Streitkräfte der Grenzkontrolle und der
inneren Sicherheit. Ein völlig anderes Szenario
als das der Vereinigten Staaten, deren Armee fast
vollständig darauf ausgerichtet ist, mit ihren
Streitkräfte den ganzen Globus zu beglücken.
Und ein letzter Punkt: Nachbarn und Verbündete.
China ist zur regionalen Großmacht im
asiatisch-pazifischen Raum geworden,
aber sein Einfluss ist nicht so überwältigend,
wie es auf den ersten Blick scheint.
Die chinesische Marine ist zum Beispiel die
mächtigste in der Region, aber sie stellt nur
etwa 30 % der Seetonnage in Südostasien. Südkorea,
Japan, Indien, Taiwan, Australien und Vietnam
legen sich nämlich auch mächtig ins Zeug bzw.
ins Wettrüsten und machen den Wettbewerb
so hart wie sonst nirgendwo auf der Welt.
Vor allem natürlich aus dem Grund,
weil die meisten dieser Länder nicht nur keine
Verbündeten Peking sind, sondern den Chinesen
eher skeptisch bis feindlich gegenüberstehen
und darüber hinaus Verbündete der USA sind.
Tatsächlich haben die Vereinigten Staaten mit
immer mehr Ländern Militärbündnisse geschlossen.
Ergo: auch in diplomatischen Angelegenheiten
werden sie den Pseudokommunisten in Peking
wohl noch auf unabsehbare Zeit weit voraus sein.
Natürlich weiß niemand, was die Zukunft
bringen wird. China ist sicherlich eine
Supermacht und ein Land mit enormem Einfluss
geworden. Es wird ganz bestimmt nicht in der
Bedeutungslosigkeit verschwinden, sondern
sich stark bemühen, die genannten Defizite
so gut es geht zu kompensieren. Aber
die Wahrheit ist nun mal, dass es nach
dem heutigen Stand der Daten immer noch weit
hinter den Vereinigten Staaten zurückliegt.
Und was noch viel wichtiger ist: Alles
deutet darauf hin, dass die Kluft nicht nur nicht
schrumpft, sondern sich sogar noch vergrößert.
Denn wie heißt es so schön: „Der ärgste
Widersacher des Guten ist nicht der Schlechte,
sondern der Bessere!“
Tja, tut mir jetzt echt Leid für all jene, die
keine so großen Fans der weltweiten Ami-Dominanz
sind, aber was die wirtschaftlichen
und militärischen Kapazitäten angeht,
können wir wohl mit an Sicherheit grenzender
Wahrscheinlichkeit sagen, dass die Vereinigten
Staaten den Ton angeben werden. Von kultureller
Macht und Demographie ganz zu schweigen.
So, nachdem
du so weit gekommen bist und mir derart geduldig
zugehört hast, kommst du nun auch endlich zu Wort:
Konnten wir Deine
Vorurteile über das sino-amerikanische Wettrennen
um die neue Weltordnung über den Haufen werfen?
Oder hast Du das alles schon
gewusst – oder zumindest geahnt?
Wie wird sich deiner Meinung nach
der wirtschaftliche und militärische
Wettbewerb zwischen diesen beiden Mächten weiter
entwickeln? Gehörst du zu denjenigen, die glauben,
dass China die Macht der USA doch irgendwann
übertreffen wird? Dann schreib und doch bitte,
welche Argumente dafür sprechen würden.
Wie immer sind wir auf all Eure Meinungen zu
diesem Thema gespannt. Ich hoffe also, dass Dir
dieses Video gefallen hat. Falls ja, gib uns bitte
ein Like und teile es auch mit Deinen Freunden.
Mach’s gut und bis bald!